you know what's going on with Benjy
nobody does it's really repulsive why
did he wear a bathing suit yesterday
that's what I want to know what he does
it's really repulsive power right he
wears these overalls right right and
then he's got a t-shirt on but he takes
free stuff from here yeah so it doesn't
matter whether it fits I'll just put it
on little baby rises over the belly
he'll Bend up to pick something over up
and on and the sides will just come up
and the the overalls just make the fat
come right out are you letting yourself
go like that Benjy well I'm heavy but
there's no but I kid I kid I could take
on anyone here and wrestling and beat
them and hey you two fight people no no
I'm just saying you're saying what's in
shape and everything huh I think I could
beat you all right go ahead you two guys
fight right now he's ready to fight you
hey let me go throw a t-shirt on I gotta
go
tango urinate real quick yeah go ahead
all right good wrestling match
Benji's gonna fight Gary Dell'Abate what
does it show come to let these two
idiots wrestle aren't they gonna kill
each other
chuckle relman have to choose their uh
really know what Gary you're gonna
wrestle this gang I know you'll get him
I mean I think I can I haven't wrestled
in a bunch of years but I don't think
Benjie knows any moves Angie's no
athlete but yeah he outweighs me by
about he's gonna sit on you Gary's gonna
flip him in two seconds I'm gonna try I
don't know what you know he outweighs me
by a lot maybe put some of the bigger
guys around the side so if somebody goes
flying to the Sun I don't get hit God
you don't have a jock strap on us or
underwear on oh man all right Ben do you
want to wrestle Gary girl I said guy
opinion about a minute you're gross
bababooey fightin benji that's no good
get out you don't need no man I don't
need a man I don't you need a man his
home his whole package is hanging out
all right when I say go you mark what I
don't know it this was kind of dangerous
look like you guys kill each other
nobody scored any points I was trying to
get him down but he should be able to
just knock me right off maybe your eyes
are already you look like that's why I
stopped it I feel like I just rode the
mechanical ball